derweil rotiert in berlin das
personalkarussell die spd zum beispiel
hat ein neues power couple lars
klingbeil wird der neue vorsitzende an
saskia esken seite und das ist wirklich
eine perfekte mischung der knuddelige
lars neben der eher links saskia im
grunde eine neuauflage von sozi und
sträucher da ist da ist für jeden was
dabei so völlig offenes rennen dagegen
um den vorsitz der cdu bis nächsten
mittwoch müssen sich die kandidaten
melden und ja favorit bei den
buchmachern ist ganz eindeutig friedrich
merz ja da fehlt zwar noch seine
offizielle bewerbung aber alle wissen
der märz versucht garantiert zum dritten
mal garantiert und warum auch nicht
warum man nicht märz ist gestern 66
geworden glückwunsch das heißt bei der
nächsten bundestagswahl ist der mann
gerade mal süße 70 ja natürlich junge
besen kehren gut
aber die alte bürste kennt die ecken
welche alte bürste
weiter das ding oben auf seiner glatze
oder was ja wenn man selber einer hat
darf man solche witze machen märz
friedrich merz das wäre die rückkehr zur
konservativen cdu der 90er getreu dem
aktuellen trend wer braucht schon neue
ideen wenn der alltag hallo wetten dass
ja
ist ja der trend ausgerechnet beim
bundesverband der lesben und schwulen in
der union hat herr merz eine mögliche
kandidatur angekündigt und ja das passt
wirklich super denn wir erinnern uns
erst letztes jahr hat er gesagt er könne
sich sogar einen schwulen kanzler
vorstellen also ich sag mal so über über
die frage der sexuellen orientierung
das geht die öffentlichkeit nichts an
solange sich das im rahmen der gesetze
bewegt und so lange es nicht kinder
betrifft
im sauerland gilt so was schon als vogue
meine damen und herren für einige nord
und übrigens sehr interessant dass merz
immer um weihnachten herum versucht cdu
vorsitzende zu werden immer weihnachten
das ist schon
das ist ja
sehr schön
sehr gespannt er wird sich immer um
weihnachten das ist eine tradition dass
gibt es jetzt sogar schon als kinderbuch
mit friedrich merz als der grinch
beziehungsweise als der prinz wie der
grinch sich jedes jahr weihnachten
versaut ich bin der clinch mit vornamen
fritz es ist weihnachten ich will den
parteivorsitz
doch meine partei die hat sie nicht alle
und nimmt stattdessen wie saarland
schnelle drei jahre später das könnt ihr
nicht machen ihr wählt also ernsthaft
den hobbit aus aachen
verlieren kriegen röttgen das geht
eigentlich nicht es sei denn sein
einziger gegner bin ich macht nix
nächstes jahr da gehe ich aufs ganze und
verliere ich knapp gegen eine
zimmerpflanze
ist die tradition
der klink
ja
kurz zur realität das kinderbuch liegt
völlig daneben ich glaube friedrich merz
packt das diesmal natürlich über den
sommer er hat die unterstützung der
mittelstands-union der
wirtschaftsverbände und auch viele
deutsche prominente freuen sich dass
merz noch mal antritt manche schicken
sogar grüße also einer halo friedrich
ich bin ein anderes habe ich schon sehr
sehr oft versucht deutschlands superstar
zu werden immer wieder hat aber nicht
geklappt friedrich du und ich haben die
gleichen spirit haben das gleiche talent
deswegen gibt nicht auf irgendwann
kommen unsere große stunde männer das
glaubt an dich
heilige ist ganz feine geste
ist ich glaube auch an friedrich merz
denn wer soll es sonst werden jens spahn
hat diese woche aufgegeben weil er
umfragen lesen kann und der einzige
ernst zu nehmender rivale ist dieser
mann norbert röttgen
ewiger spitzname muttis klügster tritt
immer an gewinnt garantiert nie so und
dann ist da noch neuerdings der
überraschungskandidat ja helge braun
kanzleramtsminister er trägt seit jahren
der chef in die tasche hinterher und er
passt perfekt zur ära merkel dan brown
ist von beruf tatsächlich gelernt haben
accuse arzt
und ganz offensichtlich hat er sich
selbst anästhesie rdx anders lässt sich
das dauergrinsen nicht erklären
aber sie grinsen dabei und deswegen gehe
ich mal davon aus dass wir morgen in der
sache von ihnen mehr hören werden für
die mitglieder und auch für die
persönlichkeit helge braun der
kanzleramtsminister herzlichen dank für
das gespräch
ja wie gesagt herzlichen glückwunsch
herr mehr herz
eigentlich nichts zu verlieren ich sag
mal wenn's fritzen ich wird stressig
eine alte bürste das schwöre ich so ganz
andere frage wie läuft es derweil
eigentlich so auf dem weg zur ampel zur
neuen regierung da war ja wir erinnern
uns sehr viel harmonie am anfang heute
sehr dass berühmtes elfi wahrscheinlich
eher so aus
die grünen die grünen hört man werden
total untergebuttert von spd und fdp in
ihrer not an die grünen sogar einen
hilferuf an umweltverbände geschickt die
sollten doch bitte druck machen auf
liberale und setzten damit dass doch
noch was wird mit dem klima total als
nächstes ruf berbalk wahrscheinlich die
tiere des waldes zu hilfe
aber die werden mittlerweile auch alle
fdp so seit dieser woche sind die ampel
arbeitsgruppen zwar durch aber was man
da bis jetzt aufgeschrieben hat bei
denen das weiß ja keiner los verraten
immer was ja das müssen sie in der
gesamten diskussion ist am ende wird
alles sicherlich diskutiert werden das
kann nur der herr wissen machen ich
glaube der hat auch nichts zu sagen
heute bloß schnell an den kameras vorbei
funktioniert aber nicht immer
ja wir bürger erfahren nach wie vor
nichts von den ampel verhandlung aber
nach allem was so durchsickerten müssen
in diesen gesprächen wohl vor allem die
armen grünen kröten schlucken ich gab
statt sie wie früher über die straße zu
tragen kurz gesagt da ist noch viel zu
klären zwischen den ampel parteien und
wären überall in deutschland
weihnachtsmärkte aufgebaut werden verrät
dietmar wischmeyer wie es ausgeht
wo sie anna uns wird eine ampel geboren
die supermärkte quellen über mit
spekulatius und wer uns bis weihnachten
noch so auf die nüsse geht verrät der
ampel adventskalender ich prophezeie
nach wochenlangem streit überschrift
größten und pendlerpauschalen setzen
sich die grünen überraschend doch noch
in einem punkt durch
130 auf landstraßen allerdings soll es
mindestgeschwindigkeit besser als nichts
und ab ende november werden dann endlich
ämter verteilt raten sie mal wer
außenminister werthein nicht werburg die
ganze doch nirgendwo hin schicken schiri
you sing die seit
januar auf
deutsch ich heiße christian lindner und
eröffne eine herrenboutique in wuppertal
und wenn neuer gesundheitsminister wird
ist er eh klar ja karl lauterbach putzig
schon raus für seinen traumjob
fragen dazu an den
spd-gesundheitsexperten karl lauterbach
genommen
ein seltenes naturschauspiel der gemeine
video haupt in der mauser lauterbach
gesundheitsminister natürlich ein herber
verlust für markus lanz bei dem unser
karl schon in die kulisse ein gewachsen
ist noch vor dem dritten advent wird der
neue klimaminister habeck bayern
verpflichten endlich windräder zu bauen
eine kriegserklärung
daraufhin schlägt markus mavericks söder
die bayerische luftwaffe richtung berlin
der angriff kann zum glück nicht
stattfinden weil das zulässige
höchstgewicht im cockpit überschritten
wird so nikolaus rum kapiert die ampel
dass man sie reingelegt hat die
mietnomaden von der groko haben ihn ein
sack voll ungelöster probleme
hinterlassen
klimaflüchtlinge corona belarus alles
hoffnungslose baustellen ach komm
wenigstens hat unser runter gerockt das
land inzwischen eine funktionierende
hauptstadtflughafen oder der
hauptstadtflughafen ber bleibt ein
pannen airport wie die
betreibergesellschaft mitteilte ist das
trinkwasser durch keime verunreinigt
magen darm erkrankungen mit durchfall
und erbrechen können die folge sein oh
ja jetzt hat ihn auch noch einer in den
runden wissen vielen dank auch wenn dann
am tag vor der geplanten vereidigung von
olaf scholz endlich auffällt dass die
programme von fdp und grünen überhaupt
nicht zusammenpassen fürchtet euch nicht
denn hinter der 420 wartet für genau den
fall der perfekte jamaika ersatz kanzler
richtig unser armin noch bis januar im
amt und sein motto passt zu deutschland
wie der sprichwörtliche arsch auf den
eimer
liebe mitbürgerinnen und mitbürger
es ist egal wer die nächste regierung
anführt und mit dieser minimal von uns
zusammen geschnittenen frohen botschaft
und lasse ich sie in die besinnliche
vorweihnachtszeit gott steh uns allen
bei
[Applaus]
nein ich mache hier gar nichts mehr
bevor ihr nicht den kanal abonniert und
nike dallas
ich hab die schnauze voll
loslassen abo da